and then I get behind this douche and a
red Mercedes and um he's doing
that thing where he now he's 10 car
links behind because but it's because
he's staring at his phone he
literally has it like up in front of his
face you know what I mean he's not even
doing like you know the glancing down
like you're counting cards or whatever
the these cheats do and get their
hands smashed by the guys at casino
right he has it held up in front of his
face like he's taking a selfie and he's
letting car after car and so finally I
beep at him what does he do he puts his
window down and he's got his hand like
oh what the yeah look we're in
traffic like what is your problem